imagine thinking that it was a bad thing
by the way for a man to say that it's
their job to take care of women
remember when that was Noble
you remember I don't remember when the
Titanic was taken I don't remember all
the women complaining that they were on
the boats first with children no no
were they like no no
I'm staying here man you take the boats
I've got this no because that would be
weird that would be make no sense right
and now we're warped right so this now
now we've been programmed as women to
think that when a man says it's my job
to take care of a woman you're supposed
to be offended by that instead of saying
to yourself well that's a fundamentally
decent man that thinks that's his job
and it's going to work his butt off to
make that happen warped Society don't
play the game